The Joe Rogan experience. That's
good stuff. That's what I mean.
I feel like that is the pinnacle of
where this medium can take us. Watching.
Like can say he was in an extreme state.
What about when you could go
by be comfortable, capable.
You become comfortable and creases
are listened to that podcast.
Like I go on runs, I'd listen to
this and I thought fucking hell man.
Where else are you going to get this
content? Whereas that got you into this.
There's no one would ever
agree to it anywhere else.
That's the thing that you'd never get a
group of people whose jobs depended upon
keeping the show on the air,
whether they're producers or executives.
They would never agree to that.
They'd be like,
you can't have that crazy fucker on,
you can't have this on can of
Eddie Bravo on all the time.
He thinks dump world is flat.
Stop this cause you traveling
between such a loaded,
diverse and unusual ideas and,
and sort of the theme of Alex Jones
is as well is that he's lucky.
He demonstrates to a point that there's
voracity in what he's saying some things.
Yeah, he's right about a
lot of things. You know,
we were just talking about animals,
human hybrids.
We started pulling up these studies where
they actually have done studies where
they've tried to create animal human
hybrids, non-viable, an animal,
human embryos to trying to grow
human organs in different animals.
And there's all sorts of weird
scientific shit that we're doing.
Imagine what they're doing in
China behind walls. Look at this.
China's latest cloned monkey
experiment is an ethical mets.
They used CRISPR to add human genes
into monkey genes and there's like five
monkeys. This happened back
in January and I don't do,
this is a fucking horror movie.
This is a hard,
but this is how the horror movie begins.
Why did you think that one,
if that's what's being revealed.
The truth is Darker Das for sure,
for sure.
They're trying to create super soldiers.
Someone is trying to create some
super soldier, some half champ,
half human super intelligent,
murderous thing that's powered by remote
control passing and all could objective.
No, I don't see a good outcome for the
superintelligent murderous remote control
[inaudible] being what?
If you could send those superintelligent
murders chimps to go kill Isis now.
Now we've got a reason to get them
out there. Now we need, and we look,
we've got a nice contract with the defense
contractor and they're gonna tell us
how we lubricate the passage to
the murderous monkeys is isis.
That's the function of Isis in the
cultural conversation is to justify it.
The monkey sell watches.